what solve leak code 3 longest substring
without repeating characters or back to
a classic leak code problem the third
one so this one's pretty simple we're
just given a string and we want to find
the longest sub screen without any
repeating characters right like how
these three don't have any duplicate
characters ABC this one has two A's so
this would not count as a substring
without repeating characters and we only
need to return the length of this
substring so the first idea that comes
to my mind at least is so just check
every single substring check if it has
any duplicates if it doesn't then it
then we're just going to take the
longest one of those strings and return
the length so how would that algorithm
run okay first we'd start at a we want
to get every substring starting at a so
just this one a well that doesn't have
any duplicates a B that doesn't have any
duplicates a C that doesn't have any
duplicates either and then we get to
this first duplicate a we have two A's
now but remember we're checking every
single sub screen starting at this first
a so we're gonna keep this algorithm
going even though we don't have to every
substring we get after that like see how
we're doing it every single substring
after is also gonna have duplicates so
do we even need to check all of these
starting at value a this is the repeated
work that we're gonna eliminate with our
very fundamental technique the sliding
window so we want to only check sub
strings without any repeated characters
so let's actually just do that let's
make sure that our window right our sub
array our substring is always not
containing any duplicates so once we get
to this next a we're gonna say well now
we have to a so we need to start
removing from the left wing to start
shrinking our sliding window until we no
longer have duplicates so I'm gonna say
remove this one from our substring now
our substring runs from here from the B
all the way to the a now it's perfectly
valid so now we can keep going it's
still only length three though so now
so we're gonna add this bead but wait a
minute now we have two bees but my
question is how would we even know
instantly whether we had a duplicate or
not well we can use a set for that sets
will only contain one of each character
so we'll automatically know if we have a
duplicate we can check it instantly so
we're going to check that we have two
bees so now we're going to keep popping
from the left we're going to keep
shrinking our window from the left until
we don't have until we remove a bee and
we're gonna see that the first one we
remove is the Beast and now we're done
so now our substring runs from this C
all the way to this D now we're gonna
add another character once again we have
a duplicate and once again we can
literally just remove the farthest left
character and now we're valid again no
more duplicates we're running all the
way from A to C next we add a B the
interesting thing about this is that now
we have to remove this a because we have
to shrink our window our sub string has
to be contiguous so we have to remove
this a but notice we still have two bees
in our substring so we got to remove
another character we have to remove this
B so now our substring runs from C to B
so we are valid again but now our
substring is only length two next we'll
get to the last B last character we're
adding and C yep it's a duplicate again
and don't forget that as we're removing
these characters from the left we're
removing a C we're not just removing it
from our window but we also have to
remove it from our set because our set
is going to correspond to all the
characters inside of our substring that
we're at so we have to remove our see
from the window and move it from the set
we have to take this B and do the same
thing and now we have no more characters
to add with this sliding window
technique which is a very fundamental
technique that you'll probably see a lot
more in a lot of different problems we
can cut the time complexity down to Big
O of n we just have to go through the
entire list well we might have to add
and remove values from our set but
that's a very quick operation the memory
complexity because of our set is also
going to be Big O of n because potential
every character and the string could be
unique and will add all of them to our
set and I didn't really show it while we
were going through the problem but we
would want to maintain what's the
longest substring we found in our case
it was obvious that the long as we found
was of length three so I remember the
first thing we need to do is get a set
to make sure we have all the characters
in our window so I'll call it character
set and we're going to do a sliding
window so any week so we need two
pointers a left pointer and a right
pointer to determine our sliding window
our left will be initialized to zero and
our right pointer is going to
continuously be changing as we visit
every character so I can just use it in
this for loop so the right pointer is
going to go through every single
character now remember if we get to a
duplicate character that means we have
to update our window and our set so
while this character that we just visit
at the right pointer s of R is equal is
already inside our character set meaning
it's a duplicate then we got to update
our window so we have to take the left
character and remove it from our set so
character set dot remove the leftmost
character and then of course we have to
update that left pointer incremented by
1 and we're going to keep doing this
while that duplicate remains in the
character set after we've removed all
duplicates then we can just add this
rightmost character to our set and since
at this point we know for sure that our
substring doesn't have any duplicates we
can potentially update ours our result
variable which I never declared so let
me declare it up here result is
initially going to be 0 and now we can
update our results so we can potentially
make it larger than it is if the current
window size is greater than what it is
right now which we can compute by right
minus left plus 1 and then at the end
once we've gone through the entire or
substring we can return the result if
this was helpful leave a like in
subscribe and thank you for watching